écoute Marinette on sait que tu as
toujours été
miss catastrophe
c'est cool
mais là ça se voit que tu a buggé moi
j'ai buggé oui tu as carrément flashé
sur Adrien le tombeur
elle est vraiment étrange
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
découvrez comment tout a commencé
tu es l'aîné
le sort du monde est entre tes mains
j'avais oublié que ça crée toujours à ce
moment là
et toi tu es censé être quoi une
pastèque
répété le phénomène mondial de chaos et
la solution je vais réduire le monde
ensemble
la première fois au cinéma vous devez
vaincre le papillon pour ça il vous faut
le combattre ensemble je suis prêt pour
la bagarre
nous sommes plus forts
[Musique]
besoin d'un coup de main
mais qui sont ces deux héros je vous
aurais ladybug et chat noir
miraculous le film encore heureux que
Marinette soit à la maison